all right so many villains to choose
from sadly in the midst of a national
emergency but well there are two
hospital executives hoping that Donald
Trump's supporters get infected with
coronavirus such nice people trace
Gallagher has that report yeah Shawn
this was a Facebook back and forth
between two hospital executives in the
Buffalo area it began when one of them
posted an article about President Trump
being hesitant to pay General Motors to
make ventilators one exec wrote quoting
here Trump supporters need to pledge to
give up their ventilators for someone
else and not go to the hospital and the
other exec responded quoting I think
they should be the only ones in packed
churches on Sunday not only did the
exchange go on it got a bit more
aggressive quoting now they should
barricade themselves in there meaning
the churches and ride this out and she
continued by saying this quote also
don't cash your stimulus check it's all
a hoax choose some ibuprofen and be on
with your day one of the women was
placed on leave and then fired the other
is on leave pending an internal review
and it's notable this story has gotten
very little pick up in the national
media Shawn shocking there too
information crisis trace Gallagher thank
you